[ Cheers and applause ]
-I thought it would be fun to
play a game that Chrissy Teigen
actually inspired,
it is called Pour It Out.
-She inspires a lot.
-She really does, right?
-She does.
-Here's how it works,
each shot sits on a coaster,
which has a personal question
written on it.
You will read
the question silently,
but you'll give your answer
out loud
and you'll have to choose
whether you share
what the question was
with our audience
or take a shot
and keep it a secret.
However you must reveal
at least one question
during the course of the game.
-Are you ready?
-Tonight America's gonna finally
get to get all of the answers,
just not all the questions.
[ Laughter ]
All right, you ready to play
this, buddy?
-Let's do it, let's do it.
-You can go first.
-Go first?
-Yeah.
-We're starting down here?
-yeah move the shot off
and read the question on the
bottom of the coaster.
-All right let's see.
Let's do this.
Hmm.
-So just say the answer.
-I d--um, uh.
-It depends.
-Mm.
-But, but, but, but, uh, I'm
gonna say Chadwick Boseman.
-Okay. depends,
Chadwick Boseman.
-So wait, now. So wait --
-Who's got better abs?
-You or...?
-So do I have to, at this point,
-You can either, you can take
the shot and not tell us
anything about this, but I
really kind of want to know
what Chadwick Boseman did or...
-Okay, so all right, this is
the question,
"Who would win in a fist fight
Chadwick Boseman
or Sylvester Stallone.
But I, I, I know.
-Whoa! Really?
-Hey, hey, hear me out.
Hear me out. Wait.
-Rocky?
-Does Chadwick get to
bring the suit?
-No!
-Does he get to bring the suit?
-He can bring the suit, but.
-If he bring the suit,
I don't know.
A suit? Rocky? I'm not sure.
Is it "Rocky IV" Rocky,
and Chadwick no suit?
Then I might pick
"Rocky IV" Rocky.
-You got too deep right now.
Too deep.
-I'm just saying.
I'm just saying.
-I'll give it to you.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
This shot is called by the way,
"A Kick in the Raspberries".
-"Kick in the Raspberries"?
-"Kick in the Raspberries".
-It's a good name.
-Um.
-Yeah.
-Uh, uh... cow, yeah.
-Yeah?
-A tooth brush.
-A tooth brush?
[ Laughter ]
-A tooth brush
from Jerry Seinfield.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys weren't
on OZ together, so.
-I mean, I --no, no, we're
[ Laughs ]
-Actually, I should have said
the question or else people
are just gonna think
it's weird, yeah. Uh.
-Whatchu doing, whatchu doing?
-Have you ever stolen --
-We have two more -- okay.
-Have you ever stolen anything
from a celebrity?
-A toothbrush?
-Here's what happened,
this is true story.
I went to --
well, here's what I did,
I snuck into the season
finale of "Seinfield"
with my friend, Barry Sobel,
and I snuck into this thing,
I lied my way
into the taping and went to
the last-final-ever taping of
"Seinfield"
-Okay.
-And at the end they invited
everyone to the floor
to have a champagne toast.
He didn't know who I was, and I
didn't know anything.
And was like, [Seinfeld voice]
"Everybody come to the floor.
Have a toast." [ Normal voice ]
And I go down to the floor.
And I go, "I can't believe I'm
on the set of "Seinfield" I go,
"I love the show so much I got
to take something."
-That's pretty legit. Actually,
I would do something like that.
-So I have a tooth brush
from his bathroom.
-How much do you think that
would go on eBay?
-I know, isn't that something?
I'll tell you.
-That just raised the value,
just now.
-You did just there.
-Just now.
-All right, good. We're not
drinking tonight. Here we go.
-All right, let's do it.
You're being very open
and honest.
♪♪♪♪
-[ Sighs ] Uh.
-Wow.
-Tessa Thompson.
-Test of times?
[ Audience murmurs ]
-Whoa!
No! No! Don't, no music.
No music.
-No, you have to explain it.
-We should stop it right now.
-No, then just explain it
in your head, dude.
-Tessa Thompson? Whoo! And he
took the shot immediately.
Oh, my God.
Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo. man.
-I'm going to hear it, right. I
know I'm gonna hear it tomorrow.
-You definitely are. Absolutely.
Going to hear the music.
-By the way this shot called
"The Wakanda Sunrise".
-It was pretty good.
-Yeah.
-Oh, Wakanda? Aw, that was cute.
-There you go.
-That was good, right?
"Wakanda Sunrise".
♪♪♪♪
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
That's not my voice.
-Was that, was that? [ Laughs ]
[ Indistinct chatter ]
-Yes.
Once with Winona Ryder.
[ Audience "Oh's" ]
-Oh. Oh! Oh-ho-ho.
-Don't you play that noise.
-Well, what is it?
-Play my music.
-It's all in your head.
-No. [ Laughs ]
-No, I should say what it is,
because that would just
make it sound weird.
-Oh, come on!
-It's kind of funny though. Have
you ever lied to the paparazzi?
I was with Winona Ryder once.
-Mm-hmm.
It was one, anyway, we were just
hanging out, no big deal.
-Okay. Uh-huh. Just hanging.
-No music.
-Yeah, no music.
-And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
There's a little bit of music.
Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
No. No. No. No. I don't want any
music, no.
But, we were --
she was dropping me off,
I had to go to some meeting
at this thing,
I was getting out of her car,
and she goes,
There's all paparazzi out
there." And I go, "Oh, yeah."
And she goes, "Why don't you,
you know, act like
we're getting into a giant fight
and slam the door?"
Getting out of the car.
-Oh, man.
So I never yell,
I don't really lose my temper.
I go, "All right."
So I got out of the car.
And I was like, "I kid you --
got to --" or make something up.
Slam the door.
-Uh-huh.
And I went back in there, and
dude, it was all over the press.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy Fallon and Winona Ryder
get in this giant fight.
-I'm gonna do this shot anyway
just because I feel like
having a couple drinks.
-That's a good one.
Ain't it?
-Yeah a little cinnamon-y.
-Mm-hmm.
-A little something back there.
-All right. Here we go.
-This looks like,
I don't even know what this is.
-Well, this is the final round.
For this one, we're both going
to answer the same question.
-Is that what we're gonna do?
-If we choose not to reveal
what it was, we both have to
take a shot, okay?
-Okay.
-So we can do that.
But I think the audience
would kill us.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. This shot is called
the "Vodka Flocka Flame".
-"Vodka Flocka Flame"?
-That is a great name,
for this shot.
-That is a great name.
-Vodka Flocka Flame
that just no.
-Oh, I get it. With the little
light. Okay, the flame, got it.
-Okay. could you do that or no?
-I could do that.
Can you do that?
-I don't know if I can do that.
Because I don't know
if anyone has, would you do it?
-I'd do it if you'd do it.
[ Drums ]
-No, no! We're no!
Hey, stop them. No, no.
Not doing that, no stop.
That's not what that meant.
-That's not
what that meant before.
-No it's not what it meant
before. It never meant that.
-That never meant nothing.
-There has been no music
the whole time. Hello.
-Ever. It's all in our heads.
-Okay. I think we do it.
-Okay let's do it.
-Read the last text
from a celebrity
that's in your phone right now.
-That's in your phone right now.
-All right.
-I just don't know
if any celebrities text me.
[ Laughter ]
-You got some texts, man,
I'm sure.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no. Stop, stop!
-I won't tell them.
I won't read the name. I won't
read the name, I promise.
I will, dude, Wakanda forever,
dude, I swear I would not.
-Okay, I got you.
I got you. I got you.
-All right, ready?
-All right, yeah.
-Can you say it?
-Yeah, I can say it.
-All right. Who's it from?
-It's from Shameik Moore.
-Oh, it's from Shameik Moore.
-Yeah, Shameik Moore.
He stars in "Spiderman into
the Universe" -- Spiderverse".
-He's fantastic by the way.
-Awesome movie. Yeah.
-He's unbelievable, do I have to
read it?
-What did he say?
-Oh, he said,
-"I seen you on stage" and "you
looked out for your boy".
"I seen you look out for your
boy on stage."
-What was that about?
-No, we, uh, I presented him
with this movie
at the Golden Globes
and the producers and stuff
were thanking people
and I just shouted him out.
just said, Shameik Moore like,
don't forget that guy.
-Wow. No way.
-It's a sweet thing.
Hey, man, he's the next
generation, he's the future, so.
You got to protect them at all
cost. What's up. What happened?
-I just got a text.
[ Laughter ]
Dude, of course.
Of course you did.
-Yeah, wait hold up.
-I just got a text from,
I guess, yeah it's from
a celebrity.
-Oh, y'all are cheating.
Y'all are cheating. [ Laughs ]
-This text says, it's from
Steve Higgins, the celebrity.
[ Laughter ]
Is there a camera I can go to.
It says, "Don't forget to get
your poop checked."
[ Laughter ]
Wait, but there's audio on it.
-It's a voice note.
-Yeah.
[ Fart ]
-Oh, man, you got it.
-There you go, perfect.
Thank you Higgins,
I appreciate that.
I'm hiding my other
celebrity texts.
Michael B. Jordan, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]